it's that time again 255 255 p.m. on a
Thursday hi my name is grace helbig am
did not know no you know your life is
different now the Country Music Awards
happen so let's review the red carpet
fashions
shall we rhetorical question özil
apologies in advance I am NOT a big
country music person surprise surprise
an area in which I do not have knowledge
about so I don't know a lot of these
people oh I will likely say their names
wrong I will likely offend you at some
point because you have feelings of
adoration towards these people that I
don't know I'm sure they're very very
talented and very fun and sweet and kind
and giving and they all got trucks and
dogs and beers and hats and tires and
baseball bats oh did I just write a
country song Lady Antebellum oh look at
you guys this is like that fun but also
like sad trio of friends in high school
that have been like best buds since they
were younger but the two guys that
clearly are in love and vying for the
attention of the girl and then the girl
said why are we all going to prom
together and I'll be so fun and they're
like yeah okay and then they go and it's
not that fun fun for her not for them
Jason Aldean and Britney Kerr okay
Britney don't Kerr looks like also is
that Shakira where you should care for
Halloween and then you're like [ __ ] I'm
wearing this again to the CMAs and Jason
Aldean cool hat Reba McEntire I mean I
love Reba McEntire I just think she's so
funny and she knows what she is she's
the most self-aware human cartoon I
think I've ever seen what a classic look
and she knows that she's a classic class
act kind of gal good for you Kacey
Musgraves
kc i must grieve right now cuz whose
kids Nieto did you steal that dress for
him no it's cute you look like a cake
made of tulle that's fun I love cake and
I'm a huge tool so look Brian and
Carolyn Boyer that's a cool dress you
kind of look like Jenny McCarthy and
there is my fully developed observation
you guys look happy and healthy and like
you don't have any problems in your
relationships good for you Rascal Flatts
you
guys look like country singers and I
like that there is from like left to
right a progression of less and less
sincere facial expressions Jennifer
Nettles
I like your name who took your sleeve
who took that from you
that's offensive I hope you find your
sleeve Faith Hill and Tim McGraw oh just
the classic country couple being classic
and country you guys look like country
Ken and Barbie oh so there's a little
bit like faith couldn't decide if she
wanted to go with the short gown to the
long gown so she just put it both on
said it gotta have faith that's my
favorite country song about the limp
Biskit cover not the Joyce Michael
originally no Garth Brooks and Trisha
Yearwood look at you guys good you
always look so startled attrition what's
happening in your armpit area that me
that's an excellent way to conceal pit
stains but it's also a little confusing
is that why Garth is so startled cuz he
thought you're wearing a normal dress
then you went like this he was like oh
hey there Nicole Kidman you just took my
soul didn't you you just looked right
into my soul and you snatched it with
your eyebrows Sharon Stone was there for
a reason
what is Sharon how is she associated
with what but she looks gorgeous but I'm
just malfunctioning a little bit son
could you test why she's there but she
looks great
what are your earrings Oh for a second I
thought she was working just like big
middle fingers dangling down from her
ears like this I was gonna be like
iconic honestly truly but I just turned
out they're beautiful earrings
she's like town Dierks Bentley and
Cassidy black first of all Dirk's
is such a funny name to say Dirk's you
guys look clean a nice - it looks a
little bit like you guys had like a
massive fight and the limo on the way
over and you're like alright let's just
get through this
that's cute Jennifer Garner also there
for a reason that is unbeknownst to me
but probably makes sense who stole your
feet where'd your feet go you want cats
sit with their legs all tucked under
they just look like my body and a head
that's what this reminds me have a
little bit how do you walk wait you just
hop around do to do like what the
candlestick from Beauty and the Beast
does cute Carrie Underwood
I like that Carrie Underwood was like oh
did someone say country Barbie because
come on Little Big Town you guys look
like you made a rule before you got on
the red carpet that was no touching that
guy looks like he is really trying hard
to maintain the rules Miranda Lambert
and Anderson East ooh sexy edgy also it
kind of looks like he kidnapped you are
you okay do you need help
spies once if you do twice if you're
like totally consenting in this
relationship you got it
Olivia newton-john yeah why not every
party needs a magician this is very sexy
Bill Nye and I am into it Jamie Lynn
Spears you're there cool this is cool
this is very like Gaga up top and Jamie
Lynn Spears on the bottom cute Gretchen
Wilson yeah why not wear a t-shirt and
stretch leggings and knee-high boots to
see amazed you do you you look
comfortable f-l king god i'd like her so
much
you look like a sexy circus ringleader
meets a lamp at a burlesque show and I
like it very much and you look just so
confident all the time just teach me
Pentatonix look at these guys they look
so good and cool an adult interesting
and not clashing but also
not like matchy-matchy to matchy you
know that thing I just like them so much
that I think my brain is melting good
for you guys
but I go that's never view of the red
carpet fashions at the Country Music
Awards let me know what looks you guys
enjoyed and um oh I forgot I forgot
and also yes I know Beyonce was there
with the Dixie Chicks and I mean there's
no reason for me to even review her
because she just looked awesome and her
performance was awesome and I have to
let you know that the MVP of the entire
night of the Country Music Awards was
[Music]
looks like I got my 2017 Halloween
costume in the works if you guys liked
this video click this button and
subscribe to my channel and give it a
thumbs up and all that fun stuff follow
me on social media yeah and so on and so
forth I don't know Billy Ray Cyrus hey
what it looks a little bit like someone
in a Billy Ray Cyrus Halloween costume
but that's cool I like that you have a
unique sense of style give a patch on
your slave is it a spaceship I can't
tell but if you do that's very trendy
Billy although only 60% convinced that
this is actually Billy Ray Cyrus and not
like a Craigslist hired look like